>> Greg: REPUBLICANS USE FEAR
TO WIN.
YESTERDAY ON CNN BILL CLINTON
DISCUSSED THAT THE DEMOCRATS
MIDTERM CHANCES I WONDER IF THE
REPUBLICANS ALWAYS CLOSE WELL
WHY?
>> THE REPUBLICANS IT WAS CLOSE
WELL WHY?
BECAUSE THEY FIND SOME NEW
WEIGHT TO SCARE THE LIVING
DAYLIGHTS OUT OF SWING VOTERS,
ABOUT SOMETHING THAT'S WHAT THEY
DID IN 2021 THEY MADE CRITICAL
REST RACE THREE SOUND WORSE THAN
SMALLPOX.
>> Greg: WHILE IT IS.
HE CLAIMS REPUBLICANS WON BY
SCARING VOTERS WHICH IS PRETTY
HYPOCRITICAL AND FEARING THAT
SCARED EPSTEIN TO DEATH.
[LAUGHS]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
ONE FEAR STOKING WHAT ABOUT
JANUARY 6 HEARINGS PER TRAINING
DONALD TRUMP VOTERS AS
TERRORISTS WHAT ABOUT HIS
HORRIFIC SPEECH IN FRONT OF
DRACULA'S CASTLE THAT SPEECH WAS
SO SCARY JOE WOULD'VE HIS PANTS
HAD HE BEEN LISTENING.
[LAUGHS]
ONE OF CLIMATE CHANGE?
GUNS?
ALL THE THINGS THAT THEY TALK
ABOUT US TOTE WITH YOUR OF
COURSE CRIME THAT IS WHO CARES
I'VE GOT PRIVATE SECURITY.
THEN I WORKED HE SMEARED MAGA SO
GOOD ONE POSTER SAYS THAT A BE
HARDER TO PULL.
I WAS IN A GROUP SIMMERED VOTERS
THEY ARE PUTTING STICKERS ON THE
CARDS SIGNS AND THE GUARDS,
POSTING THEIR OPINIONS OR
ANSWERING POLES JOE BIDEN'S
ATTACKS ON MAGA REPUBLICANS
PEOPLE WERE VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE
TO PULL A MORE STILL TO
ESTIMATE.
SO IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S
REPUBLICANS NOT THE DEMOCRATS
WHO ARE SCARED FURTHER SANITY
BUT HOW SCARY COULD THEY THINK
ARE REPUBLICANS REALLY ARE?
IT'S LIKE YOU'RE LIVING IN A
HORROR MOVIE.
♪ ♪
>> THEY CAME FROM BEYOND THE
GRAVE.
FROM BEYOND SPACE FROM BEYOND.
FLORIDA.
NIGHT OF THE LIVING
CONSERVATIVES.
DRIVEN BY AN EVIL FORCE CALLED
THE CONSTITUTION, OBSESSED WITH
GUNS, GOD GETTING UP AND GOING
TO WORK.
THEY COULD BE ANYWHERE, AT YOUR
JOB.
AT YOUR SCHOOL BOARD MEETING.
AT THAT VEGAN COFFEE SHOP WHERE
THE SERVICE IS BAD BUT THE WAIT
STAFF IS DIVERSE AND THERE'S A
HOMELESS MAN LIVING IN THE
GENDER-NEUTRAL BATHROOM.
WHILE PROBABLY NOT THERE.
[APPLAUSE]
REANIMATED CORPSES.
NOT THAT ONE.
UNDEAD, UNMASKED FEASTING ON
HUMAN BRAINS.
SO IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT, DON'T
WORRY.
YET.
NIGHT OF THE LIVING
CONSERVATIVES.
RATED R.
FOR REPUBLICAN.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: I JUST HAD A MILD
EPIPHANY I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
WITH YOU WOULD LIKE TO HEAR IT?
BOTH SIDES TEND TO USE THERE IS
A PERSUASION TOOL BECAUSE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE ONE FOR
REPUBLICANS DO IT AND THEY HAVE
LEGITIMATE FEARS OF A CRIME AT
DEMOCRATS DO IT IS ALL ABOUT
RACISM.
THAT'S WHAT LIBERTARIANS FAIL.
THEY NEVER USE FEAR AS A WEAPON.
MAYBE THEY SHOULD.
I'M PRETTY AFRAID.
WHAT ARE YOU AFRAID OF?
>> Kat: WHAT AM I NOT AFRAID
OF?
SOMETHING REALLY BAD CAN HAPPEN
AT ANY MOMENT.
ALSO IT SOMETIMES IS NOT EVEN
ANY WARNING.
>> Greg: THAT IS TRUE.
>> Tyrus: PRETTY DEPRESSING.
[LAUGHS]
>> Kat: I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
TIME WE HAVE HERE.
[LAUGHS]
OKAY I THINK IT'S ALSO NOT JUST
ABOUT THE THINGS THAT JOE BIDEN
SAYS ABOUT DON FROM SUPPORTERS
IS ALSO IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S
BEEN IN THE NEWS THE FBI
TREATING PARENTS WHO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE SCHOOL BOARD,
WILL KIDS ARE TEACHING IN SCHOOL
ESTIMATES A TERRACE, PEOPLE OF
ANY SORT OF APPRECIATION FOR
AMERICAN REVOLUTION SYMBOLS ARE
VIOLENT EXTREMISTS I THINK IS
PAST THE POINT OF PEOPLE BEING
CONCERNED ABOUT ALL IF I SAY A
SUPPORT TRUMP AND SIX OH FIVE
SAM CONSERVATIVE WHAT MIGHT THEY
DO?
I THINK THAT'S WERE MORE OF THE
CONCERN COMES FROM.
>> Greg: TERENCE, AND IS A
GOOD POINT THAT THE YOUNG LADY
IS MADE.
AFTER BERLIN WAS PRODDING.
ISN'T IT FUNNY IT'S THE MEGA
REPUBLICANS AT THE BE SCARED
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE ONES BEING
BRANDED IS DANGEROUS.
>> Terrence: IT'S CRAZY
BECAUSE I AM MAGA, I AM MAGA.
YEAH I'M MAGA BABY.
LITTLE MAGA OVER HERE.
WE ARE CALLING ME A THREAT, A
MAGA THREAT I AM 5'4" IN A WAY A
HUNDRED AND 20 POUNDS.
I'M A THREAT?
I'M SCARED TO PLAY FOOTBALL I AM
NOT A THREAT.
THIS IS CRAZY OKAY QUESTION
RIGHT THIS IS CRAZY.
THE REPUBLICANS DO NOT HAVE
SCARE PEOPLE BECAUSE THE
DEMOCRATS ARE SCARING THE HELL
OUT OF PEOPLE WITH THIS HIGH
INFLATION, HIGH GAS PRICES,
SCARING PEOPLE WITH THE IRS.
THEY'RE COMING AFTER PEOPLE FOR
$600.
WITH PISTOLS.
[LAUGHS]
IT'S CRAZY.
>> Greg: IS CRAZY.
>> Steve: I THINK IS
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT UNDER WHAT IS
MORE SCARY TODAY THAN A GALLON
OF MILK THAT COST MORE THAN A
GALLON OF GAS.
>> Greg: I LIKE THAT BECAUSE I
HATE MILK IT'S DISCUSSING IT'S
LIKE MUCUS PLUS PEONS IT'S
CATTLE MUCUS.
>> Kat: THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS THAT SCARE ME MORE THAN
MILK.
>> Terrence: I LIKE MILK I'M
SO TRY TO GROW.
I NEED MY VITAMIN D.
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: CRIME YOU DON'T HAVE
SCARE PEOPLE JUST OF THE SHOWMAN
HAPPENING.
>> Steve: ABSOLUTELY WHETHER
IT'S CRIME, THE BORDER,
INFLATION BILL CLINTON IS
TALKING ABOUT ESSENTIALLY
REPUBLICANS ARE TO DO IT, BUT
ULTIMATELY WE REALLY KNOW IS
THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE HAUNTED
BY THIS IDEA OF A RED WAVE.
WHEREAS BILL CLINTON IS HAUNTED
BY THE IDEA OF A BLUE DRESS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: TYRUS?
LAST WERE DUE.
>> Tyrus: I'M SCARY.
SPEW WHEN ARE SCARY.
>> Tyrus: I WILL WILL BE YOUR.
[LAUGHS]
HERE IS DIFFERENCE THIS IS REAL
FEAR IN THOSE FIRST WORLD FEAR.
MAGA IS THE FIRST WORLD FEAR.
THEY WANT TO WORRY ABOUT
PRONOUNS AND STUFF AND THE
REPUBLICANS LIVE DOWN THE
GROUND, BOOTS ON THE GROUND THEY
WORRIED ABOUT INFLATION,
EDUCATION, SO THEY ARE IN REAL
TANGIBLE STUFF I HATE TO TELL
YOU THIS MR. BILL CLINTON, BUT
THEY ARE AFRAID.
AMERICA IS AFRAID THEY SEE
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEMS IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
AND/OR CITIES.
IN OUR BANK ACCOUNTS SO THAT'S A
REAL FEAR THE ONLY THING YOU
HOPE IS REPUBLICANS ACTUALLY DO
SUMMING ABOUT WHEN I GET IN
THERE.
BECAUSE NOTHING IS WORSE IS
TELLING US THAT WE RECKON EYES
ARE FEARS AND NOT DOING [BLEEP].
AT LEAST THE DEMOCRATS THEY LIVE
IN SPACE SO DOESN'T MATTER IF
THEY DO NOTHING